la seconde affaire celle enquête sur
l'assassinât du petit grégory sont
incertains présumé bernard laroche était
confronté cet après midi à sa belle
soeur elle s'appelle muriel elle est
âgée de 15 ans et avait été le principal
témoin à charge contre la roche dans un
tout premier temps du moins elle s'était
ensuite rétractée ce qui n'a semble-t-il
pas convaincu le juge d'instruction le
magistrat a donc organisé aujourd'hui
une rencontre entre les deux
protagonistes sur place isabelle bechler
14h25 le fourgon de la gendarmerie amène
christian laroche au palais de justice
lors de la confrontation est arrivée
dans le bureau du juge le suspect numéro
1 va retrouver ses avocats m pro et
valère et muriel sa belle soeur de 15
ans dans les dépositions avait permis
son inculpation avant qu'elle ne se
rétracte tout le monde attend les
curieux bien sûr la presse mais aussi la
famille de bernard laroche marie-ange sa
femme accompagnée de la tante louise est
chez qui bernard laroche affirme et être
à l'heure du crime 16h la confrontation
se poursuit les avocats de la roche
viennent d'exiger la présence de six
nouveaux témoins pour confirmer son
alibi parmi eux monsieur jonque à un ami
avec lequel il aurait coupé du bois
jusqu'à 16 heures sa tante louise anne
jacob et chantal sa cousine mai à 18h30
les silhouettes furtives derrière la
fenêtre du juge reste de l'ordre de
l'énigme oui